so we have here the square root the
principal root of one two hundredths and
what I want to do is simplify this when
I say simplify it I really mean I want
to if there's any perfect squares here
that I can that I can factor out to take
it out from under the radical and so I
encourage you to pause the video and see
see if you can do that all right so
there's a couple of ways that you could
approach this one way is to say well
this is going to be the same thing as
the square root of 1 over the square
root of 200 square root of 1 is just 1
over the square root of 200 and there's
a couple of ways to try to simplify the
square root of 200 I will I'll do it a
couple of ways here square root of 200
you could realize that okay look 100 is
a perfect square and it goes into 200 so
this is the same thing as 2 times 100
and so the square root of 200 is the
square root of 2 times the times 100
which is the same thing as the square
root of 2 times the square root of 100
and we know that the square root of 100
is 10 so it's the square root of 2 times
10 or we could write this as 10 square
roots of 2 that's one way to approach it
but if it didn't jump out at you
immediately that you have this large
perfect square that is a factor of 200
you could just start with small numbers
you could say all right let me do this
in another this alternate method in a
different color you could say that's the
same color that I've been doing before
you could say that the square root of
200 say well it's divisible by 2 so it's
2 times 100 and if 100 didn't jump out
at you is a perfect square you could say
well that's just going to be 2 times 50
well I could still divide 2 into that
that's 2 times 25 let's see and it's 25
if that doesn't jump out at you as a
perfect square you could say that we'll
see that's not divisible by 2 not
divisible by 3 4 but it is divisible by
5 that is 5 times 5 and to identify the
perfect squares you would say alright
what are there any factors where I have
at least two of them well I have two
times
to here and I also have I also have five
times five here so I can rewrite the
square root of 200 as being equal to the
square root of two times two two times
two let me just from let me just write
it all out so to check the common around
of space so the square root give myself
more space under the radical square root
of two times 2 times 5 times 5 times 5
times 5 times 2 times 2 when I wrote it
this order so you can see the perfect
squares here well this is going to be
the same thing as the square root of 2
times 2 this second method is a little
bit more monotonous but hopefully it's
it you see that it works this is one way
to think about it and that they really
they boil out of the same method we're
still going to get to the same answer so
square root of 2 times 2 times the
square root times the square root of 5
times 5 times the square root of 5 times
5 times the square root of 2 times the
square root of 2 well the square root of
2 times 2 is just going to be this is
just 2 square root of 5 times 5 well
that's just going to be 5 so you have 2
times 5 times the square root of 2 which
is 10 times the square root of 2 equals
10 times the square root of 2 so this
right over here is square root of 200 we
can rewrite as 10 square roots of 2 so
this is going to be equal to 1 over 10
square roots of 2 now some people don't
like having a a radical in the
denominator and if you wanted to get rid
of that you could multiply both the
numerator in the denominator by square
root of 2 because notice we're just
multiplying by 1 we're expressing 1
square root of 2 over square root of 2
and then what that does is we rewrite
this as the square root of 2 over 10
times the square root of 2 times the
square root of 2 well the square root of
2 times square root of 2 is just going
to be 2 so it's going to be 10 times 2
which is 20 so it could also be written
like also be written like
that so hopefully you found you found
that you found that helpful in fact even
this one you could write if you want to
visualize it slightly differently you
could view it as one twentieth times the
square root of two so these are all
these are all the same thing